翻訳: Haruko NAGAI
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
「歩きたい
自分の足で」
私は今でも そう思っています
段差 階段 坂道
街には 不便がある
生活には 不自由がある
私だけではありません
障害のある方
ご高齢の方
ベビーカーを押す方
合わせたら
日本で暮らす人の３割を超えます
その人たちには
共に行動する家族や友人もいます
多くの人が感じる—
不便や不安を解消するため
私は考えました
多様な方がゆったりくつろげる 旅館
家族みんなで幸せを共有する 結婚式場
それぞれの可能性を広げる スポーツジム
ありとあらゆる場所を
行きやすく 過ごしやすくしています
お墓も その一つです
かつて霊園は 砂利道や狭い道で
多くの人が 移動しづらい場所でした
そこで これまでにない
バリアフリーの霊園を実現しました
目が見えない人も
皆と同じようにアートを楽しみたい
名画を触ってわかるようにしました
ありとあらゆる人が
楽しめる空間を実現しました
行きたい場所へ行けるかどうか
行きやすい道順はどれか
一目でわかる地図を作りました
今では スマートフォンさえあれば
どこにいても見ることができます
これらは 社会貢献のみならず
ビジネスです
大きな市場が チャンスがあります
多くの人が 求めていることだからこそ
続けていかなければいけません
広げていかなければいけません
社会性と経済性
両輪あってこその継続です
世界には 10億人の障害者が暮らしています
そして どの国でも高齢化は進みます
取り組むべきは 日本だけではありません
10年前 私は 病室にいました
歩くことを夢見て 手術を受け
毎日毎日 リハビリに明け暮れました
しかし 歩くことは叶いませんでした
夢 断たれた日
私は自ら命をも断とうとしました
でも 私の足では
飛び降りることもできませんでした
死ぬことすらできない自分に
絶望しました
病室のベッドの上で
枕に顔を押し付け 散々泣きました
けれど 人の涙は２週間も もちません
泣き明かした後 考えました
「ここまでやってダメなら仕方がない」
そう思えるまで とことん向き合おうと
可能性がないと わかっていながらも
歩くための努力を続けました
全力で
結果 やっぱりダメでした
今日も私は 車いすに乗っています
幼少期からずっと抱いた
「歩きたい」という想いは
これから先も 消えることはないでしょう
それでも 最後のリハビリを終えた時
私の心は 晴れ晴れとしていたことを
覚えています
私は 歩けなくてもできることを
探し始めました
病室を出て
猛勉強の末に大学へ入学しました
学費を賄うため
私はアルバイトをする必要がありました
コンビニ ファミレス 新聞配達
車いすの私に できることはありません
履歴書を持って 多くの会社を回ったところ
一社だけ 私を拾ってくれました
ウェブ制作の会社でした
すっかり デザインの仕事をするものと
思っていたところ
出社初日 私が任されたのは
営業の仕事でした
他の営業は 一日100件近く回ってきます
一方私は せいぜい10件程度でした
駅にエレベーターがない
建物に段差がある
お伺いすることさえ
叶わない日もありました
何とか諦めずに続けていると
「また車いすの営業が来た」
「また垣内が来てるぞ」と覚えてもらい
気づけば その会社で
一番の売上 結果を残していました
「歩けなくてもできること」だけではない
「歩けないから 障害があるから
できること」もある
私は 新たな道にたどり着きました
振り返れば
苦しいこと 辛いことばかりでした
しかし 不幸ではありません
歩けなかったからこそ
得られたチャンスがありました
出会えた人がいました
「バリアバリュー」
障害は 視点を変えれば価値に代わる
私は そう信じています
障害だけではありません
例えば 仕事が遅いとしましょう
でもそれは 人より丁寧な仕事を
しているのかもしれません
落ち着きにかけるのは
目先のことだけではなく
広い視野を持って
行動しているのかもしれません
不安になりやすいのは
人一倍 責任感が強く
最善の準備をしているのかもしれません
誰もが持っている
弱みやコンプレックスは
強みに 価値に変わる瞬間があります
もちろん すぐには難しいでしょう
でも 向き合い続けることで
信じることで
バリアはバリューに変わります
20歳の時 私は会社を立ち上げました
障害者の視点 経験 感性を生かす会社です
今 多くの仲間と
バリアをバリューへ変えています
ここで 私の人生を変えてくれた—
一人の女性との話をしましょう
私は 田んぼと山ばかりの町で育ちました
ひとたび外へ出れば 山あり谷あり
車いすでは移動が大変でした
家から学校まで
友人がいつも車いすを押してくれました
でも 私には
車いすを押してもらいたくない—
いいえ 押してもらえない人がいました
高校生のころ お付き合いしていた恋人です
小さなプライドでした
車いすを押してもらうことが
情けない 恥ずかしい かっこ悪い
そんな風に思っていました
ある日 彼女が私に言いました
「手をつないで歩きたい」 と
車いすに乗っている私と手をつなげば
目立ちます
私はすぐに断りました
彼女に冷たい視線を
浴びさせたくなかったからです
ところが 彼女はこう続けました
「付き合ってるんだから
手をつなぐのは当然でしょ」と
それから私は
片手で車いすをこぐ練習をして
彼女とはどこへ行くにも
手をつなぐようになりました
私と歩く彼女は
恥ずかしがるどころか
いつも笑顔でした
しばらくして
彼女が手をつなごうと言った
もう一つの理由を知りました
手をつないで坂道を歩いていると
私のほうが遅くなり
自然と 彼女に引っ張られる格好になります
坂道に差し掛かった時
私は 彼女へ負担をかけないように
「ここからは自分でこぐよ」と伝え
手を放そうとしました
すると彼女は手を放すことなく
笑って私に言いました
「車いすを押すなとは言われたけど
引っ張るなとは言われてないよ」と
「ありがとう」
その言葉が出るより先に 涙が出ました
家から一歩外へ出れば
私は周囲の人に手伝ってもらってばかり
口を開けば
「すみません すみません」と言い続け
下ばかり見ていました
でもこの時は違いました
顔を上げて 前を見ました
その先に 私の手を引いてくれる
笑顔の彼女がいたからです
「すみません」と言い続けた人生から
「ありがとう」と伝え続ける人生に
変わりました
彼女が彼女なりに考えたその答えに
私は救われました
「車いすだから押してあげよう」
「手伝ってあげよう」ではない
目の前の人と どのように向き合うか
どのように共に歩むか
今はそれを「ユニバーサルマナー」と名付け
私が伝え続けています
これから皆さんも 学校や職場 街中で
多様な方と向き合うことになるでしょう
どんな建物が快適なのか？
どんな製品が使いやすいのか？
どんな手助けが喜ばれるのか？
正解はありません
皆さんの考えるそれぞれの答えが
誰かの救いに繋がるはずです
ハードもハートも世界に誇れる日本を
誰もがバリアをバリューとできる未来を
皆さんと共に実現できたらと願っています
(拍手）